what's nice about doing my own stuff one
I I'm usually happy with my stuff all
right and it's also very personal all of
my writing techniques I never took any
writing classes or seminars or anything
like that read any pamphlets everything
I learned as an actor of studying acting
for six years I've basically applied to
writing the day that I sit down to do it
whatever is going on with me at the time
will find its way into the piece it has
to or the piece isn't worth making if
I'm not then you could just send a robot
out there that's just good acting that's
what you have to do you can't deny
anything all right well the same thing
with me as a writer if I was writing The
Guns of the Navarone right at the
beginning of writing it or in the middle
of writing it I I break up with my
girlfriend who I'm like madly in love
with and then my heart is is shattered
all right that's got to work into it now
the story is still about a bunch of
Commandos going to blow up a couple of
cannons all right but that pain that I'm
feeling has got to find its way into
this story or else
what am I doing